Here are some things I prepped to make my week just a little bit
easier. I'm close to giving birth,
so I made some homemade chicken stock to pop in the freezer.
I let all of that simmer for about three to four hours
while I prepped all of my other dishes.
I started off by making some raspberry crumble bars.
I baked my crust while I got started on my raspberry topping.
Once the crust was baked,
I spread all of that on top,
sprinkled some of my oatmeal mixture on top,
and then let that bake for a little longer.
Once that was cooling,
I decided to prep some smoothie bags.
I did a heavy metal detox one with banana, cilantro,
wild blueberry,
and then I've been loving mango,
so I made some mango ones as well.
I made a quick vanilla peach puree
and just let the peaches simmer on the stove
while I made my oatmeal bake.
This is a staple in our house.
We have this a lot.
So I made a double batch,
baked that for 30 minutes, and then let that cool as well.
When prepping salads,
I make sure that they store really well.
So today we did a Brussels sprout and kale salad.
I shaved some Brussels sprouts
and then added all my other ingredients to a bowl
and top that with a miso Calabrian chili dressing.
I also like having protein on hands,
so I seared off some skirt steak That I marinated the night before,
and let that rest while I moved on to making my last dish,
which was a Thai fried rice.
Used up a bunch of veggies we had in the fridge,
so it was Napa cabbage,
some broccolini, scallions, chili.
I just scrambled some eggs,
took those back out,
and then sauteed all of my vegetables.
Before adding my rice and my sauce.
Give that good mix,
and obviously had to taste test.
I blended up my peach puree,
and then bagged up my raspberry crumble bars.
These are so handy to have just throughout the week as a little snack.
I leave my oatmeal bake in the tray,
just cover it with plastic wrap.
My steak. We had half of the fried rice for lunch,
so I backed up the other half, and then moved on to my salad.
In the meantime,
lucky was straining my broth for me,
so I put that away.
And I don't like prepping a lot of food,
because I get over the flavor of things really quick,
so this was perfect.